full parking and extra foot traffic all
part of the holiday rush mary jane
belliesa takes us to downtown summerlin
where some are squeezing in that last
minute christmas shopping
bustling crowds on christmas eve as
dozens of shoppers sprawled downtown
summerlin this afternoon reagan welch
says a little rain and wind didn't stop
her from completing her shopping list
i'm shopping for my family my mom and my
siblings right now
for christmas it's a little late for my
mom so far i found a pair of slippers
and
for my siblings i think i'm just going
to find them some toys since they're
three amelia zigg along with her sister
and dad started shopping early this
morning they were on the hunt for some
good deals we're shopping for presents
for our mom
because it's christmas and
we got her
some stuff that she really needs and she
really wants and while many were
shopping for others logan dykes is doing
his own retail therapy i actually came
here to shop for myself i found these
shoes at the nike store they just
dropped them
and i had to i had to buy them you know
it's the christmas spirit shopping for
yourself mary jane bellizza live local
now